Japan is turning to new containment
measures this morning after witnessing a
surge of new infections there are now
more than 2,000 confirmed cases of the
corona virus in Japan 60 new cases were
confirmed overnight in Tokyo which is
rolling out a stay at home order in an
effort to limit person-to-person contact
rainy Inocencio has more from the
Japanese capital Tokyo does feel a
little quieter this weekend and that is
despite the governor telling all of her
residents to stay home this weekend to
try to stop the spread of the corona
virus take for example this cherry
blossom Park right behind me the city
has closed many parks just like this to
stop people from congregating right now
it is actually the National social
pastime of the Year with peak cherry
blossom season happening but the
government is saying that this is in the
best interest of the public health now
just days ago Tokyo's parks still had
many people picnicking drinking and
hanging out under the trees that is
despite of course an unprecedented week
for Japan on Tuesday the Tokyo 2020
Summer Games were postponed to be held
no later than 2021 in the summer on
Wednesday
Tokyo's governor warning the city of
this weekend's advisory warning them
also of overwhelm hospitals in the
future and on Thursday the government of
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a set up a
National coronavirus task force now
that's important because it paves the
way for him to declare a national
emergency and that would empower the
governors of Prefecture --zz here
similar to states in the u.s. to declare
up to a three week lockdown if they so
needed that of course is what's happened
in China what is happening in Italy and
what's happening across many cities in
the United States so far here in Japan's
capital most people but not all are
heating the warning rainy Inocencio CBS
News Tokyo